let's bring in bill Plante a LA Times
columnist and of course one of the stars
for around the horn on the mothership
bill good morning how are you what's
going on I don't like all me one of the
stars I'm more like around the horn
batting practice pitcher but yeah okay
okay if you if there's a totem pole here
who's on that who's the Mount Rushmore
of around the horn I know you got this
question before and cap you ask Alex all
it counts not for himself not for this
Tony reality show it's Tony reality show
it's his it's his baby now he's the face
of the show we're all just bit parts of
his easy actor he's a he's the father
he's the father of our little family
over there he's the man so it's sort of
like LeBron with his the rest of his
teammates that well that's what we'll
find out the next 25 games won't we
yeah a little the brother I think that's
if that's the whole thing out here is a
will LeBron you know everybody says
where the Lakers make the playoffs well
well LeBron get him there will he Buy in
will the Lakers buy into him or his body
by it I mean I think that's the question
out here that everybody's asking I mean
all the furor of him coming over here
coming out here and the question is
still why is he here and I guess we're
gonna find out what do you mean by
LeBron buying in he seems since the you
know he was unable to get Luke Walton
fired they're unable to trade the guys
for interest for Anthony Davis
he seems attached the last several you
know since coming back from his injury
he seemed detached he seemed unfocused
he seems like even even even the optics
I'm sure well you know y'all discussed
that ad nauseam about him sitting on the
bench in Indiana three seats down from
everybody else I think that's symbolic
that's kind of how he rolls he's very
passive aggressive like that he just
hasn't seemed to be to be part of the
thing you asking better off the Lakers
he's his own planet I know that's a lot
of thats natural it happens you know
it's gonna happen anyway but it seems to
be leaking onto the court in a game
against Atlanta the last game before the
break he was just he had a triple-double
it was the most empty tripled
I've ever seen he was just barely there
it seemed like he was just kind of you
know walking knocking back on defense
and not helping out on defense and not
looking for teammate it's just uh yeah
and so everybody's wondering is you know
again he's his camp wanted Luke Walton
fired Jeanie buss said no he's still too
close to the end of the year his camp
one of these guys traded that you know
that blew up in their face what do you
know so now he's kind of wanted on an
island and he needs his teammates you
know his team that's the Lakers who
their leader is and it's rajon rondo
without question really you can look at
how they celebrated me yeah so that's
that's that's what I mean by that yeah
I'm also I'm wondering about this though
as we move into the offseason here
because this is this is probably the
most important offseason of LeBron
Jameses career oh absolutely because
he's got a three I mean he's got a three
year window at her the Lakers are
considering it through your window and
if he doesn't get help he's he's never
gonna get back to where he was and you
know Kevin Durant I gave Kevin Durant a
lot of hats I think they even come on
this show and has given pass so forth
we're talking about how tough for mister
player with LeBron but a lot of that is
true as far as all the furor that goes
around and all the distractions that
goes around it and and I think it's
gonna be harder for them to get somebody
to come play here given the
circumstances and if they don't make the
playoffs and if this is not a true you
know guy wants to come to the play
LeBron to say okay we can go right to
the championship we can go right to the
finals can they do that if they end up
seasons not making the playoffs can they
sell themselves as that as that and you
know yeah maybe a guy like Jimmy Butler
but I don't think that's the kind of guy
they need but also everybody was
pleading and promising that they were
gonna be patient this year what what
happened to the patience that everybody
talked about at the beginning of the
year well it was patience like okay
you're gonna break the five year playoff
drought you're gonna get to the playoffs
or gonna win a playoff round that's
enough it was that kind of it wasn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
that patient no I mean yeah and it's
it's patience like you know you'll come
in here and you'll slowly become a Laker
we hasn't really made steps to be a
Laker yet people don't feel like he
really is a true Laker yet
yeah we're talking to Bill Pulaski from
the LA Times contributor not star of
ESPN's around the warning I a couple of
years ago I could see where somebody
wants to play with LeBron now at this
age at this stage and what are you
giving up what's what's the roster gonna
look like now I would have even more
doubt so I know I'm walking into a
circus which we know it is with LeBron
but at this age at this time I don't
know if you're gonna have a long list of
guys big-name guys who were gonna want
to go into this knowing oh and that's
and I think we thought that wasn't gonna
be the case I even wrote off summer oh
my god he'll get he's a great player
they'll get great players but he missed
18 games with a groin injury and he
doesn't seem to be coming back from that
completely 100% and I think players see
this they start to say is the rubber
wearing off on the tires here a little
bit I know it's a cliche but they that
that's what people are kind of seeing
and they're kind of wondering well how
many years does he have left and if
that's if he doesn't have many years
left I'm not gonna be stuck out here
with this roster and you know and then
some of the players that were Bob Ryan
acquired himself I mean you already saw
where one of his signings Michael
Beasley is now playing for China for
pete's sake he didn't LeBron didn't do a
great job bringing guys in to compliment
him either so yeah I think that's a
that's a real that's a real concern and
and because it's based around him and is
he membered this is the same age Kobe
Bryant got the Achilles so this is the
same age Kobe kind of started going down
and all the wear and tear on him we did
I guess I thought he was indestructible
and everybody out here didn't we kind of
were blinded by that when he came here
well now we're seeing he's he's pretty
much a 34 year old ballplayer who's you
know scuffing a little bit to find his
feet and find his attitude and it's it's
kind of a scary thing to watch but also
you're looking at a guy who's 34 who's
really 36 his body's 36 I know he's
taking care of it but he's I mean he's
put two seasons of playoff basketball
which counts more than just one game and
I wonder it are they more likely to
still try to bring in Anthony Davis or
do you think that they're go out in
court free agents well I don't think
they get I don't think the good aunt
idea was at this point I think that
they've got ship has sailed
I don't think especially they don't make
the playoffs I mean they're there what
they can offer for him it's not anywhere
near what Boston can offer and
don't see them getting them at this
point oh they got to go for it Magic's
got a magics got to use his magic again
to figure this thing out because it's
gonna have to be a free agent and what
free agent will mean Cameron Durant is
not going to come here no I mean I can't
see Kyrie Irving coming back he talks
about I can't seem to come back to play
here I mean again you know I don't see
klay Thompson coming he wants to stay in
Golden State there's you know and Kawhi
Leonard is going to the Clippers so
they're you know they're they're
pickings are getting constrained Lee
slim and it's the kind of player that
can bring another championship I didn't
think his trouble and I think you can
all again LeBron comes back and we've
all heard he stays himself for the
second half of the season he stays
himself for the postseason we've all
heard that now it's time for school yeah
I just you know they got you know it was
just this calculated risk to try to
bully the pelicans and then all of a
sudden pelicans go blue so it's so blew
up in their faces it's so blue up to
make that rich pause that's a rich Paul
thing it's the same thing he tried to
get Luke Walton fired and that didn't
work either
so LeBron had not had much success in
his off the court micromanaging here and
then is that a sign of other things I
don't know but it's just not what you
know you know it starts it all starts
again on Thursday I guess you stand out
here and say you know it's a it's a it
could be the most important 25 games in
the recent franchise history to see how
they finish this thing up and I also
vested so much into this and it feels
like if they don't make the playoffs
Luke Walton is going to be fired oh
there's no question but within 24 hours
of the end of the season maybe even if
they do make the playoffs though he's
not gonna genie can save them for a year
for the end to the end of the year but
no no he's gone
so LeBron will have to pick pick to
coach it in and then what's what's that
going to look like you know and how much
faith of this team and again are these
kids he's stuck you know these guys are
stuck with each other for better or
worse and these kids don't seem like
they trust him they don't seem like they
trust him I could trust Rondo they don't
seem like they're they're born into him
as a teammate so that's all got to
change what feels like Rondo is genuine
to them and LeBron is not that's exactly
is exactly right well he's there he's
present when LeBron got hurt he started
staying away and wasn't around this
and since the injury though yeah yeah
Rhonda Rhonda was hurt he was there all
the time so no yes you're absolutely
right they really look up to here the
admiration I heard I wasn't there but
the admiration in the Boston locker room
after that game and the TD Garden was
unbelievable they talked about him like
like you know like he's our coach so yes
you're right they feel genuine to him
they don't feel they don't feel in again
they see LeBron talking and see what's
going on they see themselves on the
trade block any wonder how much he has
to do with it and yeah so it just hasn't
been I just cannot overemphasize how
disillusioning this has been again it
can all change 25 games it'll all change
and everybody be great but it's been a
disillusion in time so far for him out
here bill we appreciate your time as
always thank you thank you that's a bill
plash Kelly Times columnist and a
contributor to around the horn for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
[Music]